ثوره في عالم الطعام بعد اعطاء اداره
الاغذيه والعقاقير الامريكيه اف دي اي
الضوء الاخضر للشركه ابسيدفونس لان انتاج
لحوم الصناعيه في المختبرات بهذا اصبحت
الشركه الامريكيه الاولى التي تتلقى هذه
الرساله من اداره الاغذيه والعقاقير فيما
يتعلق باللحوم المنتج في المختبر هذه
الموافقه تمثل خطوه الرئيسيه نحو حقبه
جديده في انتاج اللحوم فالمستهلكون
الامريكيون هم في المرتبه الاولى عالميه
في الاستهلاك اللحوم وبهذا تتاح لهم فرصه
تناول اللحوم منتجع من الخلايا الخلايا
الحيوانيه هذه الحيوانات او تلويف البيئه
في تربيه ابقار بعدد اكثر اي اطلاقا غاز
ميثا بشكل اكبر
[موسيقى]
شركه الناشئه عده في انتاج ما يسمى
باللحوم المخبريه او الاصطناعيه تصنع في
الحصول على الموافقه لتسويق منتجاتها
وتعاد سنغافوره حاليا الدوله الوحيده التي
يمكن فيها بيع اللحوم المزروعه في المختبر
للمستهلكين بشكل قانوني
هذه الطريقه في انتاج اللحوم ستتيح البشره
استهلاك البروتين الحيواني من خلال اساليب
تحمي الاثار البيئيه اقل مما تسبب به
تربيه الحيوانات ولا تؤذيها هذه الكائنات
تختلف هذه المنتجات عن البدائل النباتيه
للحوم كذلك المصنوعه من فول الصويا
ومكونات اخرى مشابهه للحوم من ناحيه
الملمس ونكهه لكنها لا تحتوي على بروتينات
حيوانيه فهذه اللحوم تصنع من انسجه
حيوانيه في مفاعلات الحيويه في ظل ظروف
الخاضعه للرقابه ليكون اللحم المزروع
مطابقا للمذبوح تقليديا ومع ذلك يمكن ان
تؤدي نقاط الاسعار المرتفعه وشكوك
المستهلكين الى بطاقه تحول الى اللحوم
المصنوعه في المختبر
[موسيقى]
من الرياض ينضم الينا الشيخ ياسر جاد ياسر
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معانا طيب لما نتحدث
عن لحمه مصنعه في المختبر يعني انت ياسر
كشاف يعني الفكره مجنونه مرفوضه ام هي
مقبوله بالنسبه لكم
الفكره ممكن تكون جدا مقبوله
ليش مقبوله
عدد السكان بيزيد والشرس اللي هي المواد
الاوليه ممكن ما تكفي
للاحتياج العالمي بشكل واضح همم فقد تكون
مقبوله لحد جدا اذا كانت توفرت الاخلاقيات
الاساسيه في الصناعه يعني اذا كان ضمننا
انه المصنعين بيحافظوا على نسبه البروتين
ونسبه الدهون والمواد الحافظه
بشكل مقبول اتوقع انه ممكن تكون حلو يعني
ياسر انا بدي افهم من حيث الطعم والجوده
يعني معروف الوجه بيف من اشهر وافخم انواع
اللحوم في العالم وفي طريقه يعني لتسمين
العجل والبقره يعني ودلالها لفتره طويله
حتى نطلع بهاي النكهه من اللحم اليوم يعني
لما يجيني لحم من المختبر هل سيكون بنفس
الجوده والنكهه
احنا اكيد لازم نتفق انه اصابعنا في يد
واحده مو مو نفسه نفسه في اختلاف يعني
اكيد في في نسبه معينه هتكون موجوده من
الواجب بالكواليتي العالميه بالمستوى
الطبيعي لكن كحول انا تكلمت انه كحلول قد
تكون هذه المواد المصنعه تكفي
عدد السكان العالمي في المستوى العام
بالعموم لكن اكيد ما في ما في اكيد ما في
اي مقارنه ما بين المنتجات الطبيعيه اللي
هي ماخوذه من همم من اصولها الاساسيه بنفس
المستوى اللي احنا واقفين عليه يعني من
ناحيه الكواليتي والطعم والجوده همم انا
باتكلم كحلول قد تكون حلول يعني لكن جوده
اكيد في اختلاف واضح يعني
التوجه اليوم
الصحه
او الى الغالي والمبهر
لا اكيد طبيعي والصحي يعني انا متاكد انه
توجه العام احنا يهمنا ان الغذاء يكون صحي
ما ما في مضاعفات تكون وفي نفس الوقت يعني
هذه سنه الحياه انه ال ال الغذائي يكون
صحي يعني الاستهلاك المفرط هذا هو اللي
خلا الصناعه تحولت لوحش يعني انا كنت اقول
لو لو لو
المعايير الدوليه واضحه في التصنيع وقويه
وفي جهات تشدد الرقابه ممكن احنا نشبع
وصلنا انه يعطينا الكواليتي الاعلاميه
والصحيه والمقبوله لكن احيانا غياب بعض
العقبات العالميه والانظمه وضعف الاجهزه
اللي هي التابعه همم المنتجات هذه في
السوق هذه اللي يؤدي لمشكله طب الشيف راح
تتحمس مثلا تطبخ بلحمه مصنعه بالمختبر ولا
راح تظلك تجيب اللحمه المليئه بالدهن من
اللحام
لا اكيد اكيد انا اتحمس فعلا اني همم ندخل
التجربه هذه واستخدم المنتجات اللي هي
كحلول
منتجات تكون التصنيع في حدود معينه
للتصنيع يعني في بعض الان في صناعه ان هم
يضغطوا اللحوم يعني يجيبوا البواقي تبع
اللحوم ويضغطوها بشكل معين بدون
حيوانيه من نفس البقره وهذه يطلع يعني
اقرب ما يكون للواقعي اما باتكلم همم اما
يعني التصنيع من من مكونات مختلفه ومن
عناصر مختلفه هذه اكيد يعني يكون جوده
رخيصه واسعار جدا متدنيه وممكن تستهدف
فئات معينه انا التحدي للشيف هذا المطلوب
الشيف اذا دائما بيكون في المنطقه همم
الامنه ويبقى افضل المكونات
حق الشيف المبدع الشيف اللي يحاول انه يحل
مشاكل
للمجتمع اللي هو فيه فتوقع انه التحدي
يطلب من الشيخ ادخل التجربه دي وش